oh I think that this ramen bowl is gonna
be like 20 times the size of a normal
wall around open your eyes
[Music]
hi welcome back
the tasties making it big I'm Alvin and
I love making the giant food personally
I've been a fan of sumo wrestling for a
very long time
I've always wondered you know how do
they train what do they eat how do they
maintain that athletic prowess at such a
size so today I've invited yamas on from
the USA sumo to come in so let's go meet
him and see what he wants to eat thank
you for coming in I've always wanted to
meet a similar wrestler like you can you
tell me what it's like to be a sumo
wrestler very hard but very nice what is
the training like so we wake up at 6
a.m.
training you finish today noon 6 hours
of training yeah very important after
eat sleep why why do you sleep make big
body yeah eat and then sleep
are there any misconceptions you know
about sumo that you think need to be
addressed jancuga deposit rhetorically
connery cohesion are heresy hood of a
car to rotate a car down to today
so Tom Segura not chicken
one of my dreams is to cook for a sumo
wrestler like you what giant food would
you like me to make for you today can
you make me vomit
gyros yeah what kinds of ingredients do
you like in your ramen cashew egg okay
green onion okay
seaweed what kind of broth do you like I
don't watch don't kotsenburg oh me too
Thanks okay I have to think about this
might be tough but I think I can do it
oh thank you appreciate it
so uh I don't have to do I got to make a
giant egg I gotta make homemade
ramen broth big giant ramen noodles and
somehow make a giant pork and honestly
it's kind of a lot to deal with I think
I'm gonna have to call in some backup
I got a Fred in mind that I think could
really help me out so I'll be right back
this is my friend Inka she's a producer
at BuzzFeed she's made some amazing
videos you might have seen a lot of the
cool stuff that she's done she's amazing
in the kitchen
Dinka welcome to the show thank you
thank you have you ever made ramen
before I have not made ramen I've made
other kinds of noodles like Tony's
noodle soup okay um stir-fry noodles
well you have a lot more experience than
I do so I'm glad you're here today we're
gonna make a giant ramen full disclaimer
this isn't anything particularly new
channels have done similar versions but
we want to do our own take on it I think
what the first thing we're gonna do is
make the broth so we're gonna make a
Tong concert broth they have a lot of
meat pork feet chicken backs chicken
necks a lot of kind of odds and ends and
pieces the reason why they use these odd
cuts is because I think it adds a lot of
flavor right it's a good way to use up
like the normal cuts you wouldn't just
eat
Wow this is what the water going in
listen to the back boy let clean off any
impurities I'll be right back okay
so while the bones and the meat are
blanching we are going to charge some
vegetables and the reason we do this is
so that we can add some smokiness to the
flavor at some depth you know I like to
bring that heat all right listen to that
sizzle this is like three pounds of
onions like 25 cloves of garlic that's
what I like to see I take a while
because there's a lot of vegetables that
we have to go through yeah look great
all right
so nice and caramelized it's not ten
minutes I took a nap you know I heard do
all the hard work but I got you a tray
if you don't try your vegetables that's
also okay but always like black fits
here it really enhances the flavor right
it's like flavor bits yeah
flavor bits we have our hard vegetables
Thank You Inka for making it happen I'll
make sure I put more work in so this
group project doesn't become a failure
yeah this is what the bones look like
after being boiled and skimmed a bit so
we're just gonna take them out trying to
go fishing you see that layer of fat
that's how much stuff came out of it
this has a lot of impurities and kind of
the weird bits from the bones it's not
really that great to save so I'm gonna
go dump this out so we can get a cleaner
broth going
I'll leave the heavy labor to you sure
yeah literally it carry my weight we
have to put the bones back in here we go
oh oh that's flattered so we have the
charred vegetables really er shiitake
mushrooms love these these are so good
in every type of broth ready those these
are what is done what are those these
are leeks
okay 1 2 3 make it rain
well this is like what 3 bunches yeah Oh
scallions we got your vegetables
children thanks mom I'll get higher than
you can
this is gonna need to cook for like 8 to
12 hours because it's like a really nice
broth that cooks for a long time
basically slowly simmering it I'm gonna
take this into the back to cook we're
gonna make some ramen noodles from
scratch as you guys can see we have a
couple of ingredients here flour water
and counselee also known as lye water
it's a sort of alkaline solution I don't
want to get too scientific here but what
it does it makes noodles chewy that's
what gives it that sort of like springy
mouthfeel I've never made these before
all right let's just get to it so it's
kind of like pasta but like there's no
egg right yeah but surely
light-water kicking up a notch making a
sound oh okay yeah look at that yeah
this spring it comes back I feel like
since you did a lot of the work with the
vegetables I gotta pull my weight you
know you can't be the guy in the group
projects that just like sits back does
nothing and then just like shows up on
the last day I was like oh hey guys
how's it going oh you finished oh thanks
thanks for the ate Alvin talks a lot I'm
sorry it's the first time I've had a
friend on the show your lives just
lonely in me that's true you can tell
that there's a lot of what is it gluten
gluten yes there is a lot of gluten
because it's taking a lot of like arm
work good okay you're literally like
it's nice I don't slap how else do you
check of it smooth I'm gonna say this is
done how do you feel
we just need it let it rest a little
relax a little and then we can roll it
out into some Noons all right let's go
yes I always know it's dramatic as I
thought I'll take how do you think that
that's satisfying oh yeah yeah it's like
a mochi ice cream it is a good time
mochi ice cream would not taste like it
two out of ten do not recommend we're
just flattening out so then it can go
through the pasta machine all right so
this is currently set at zero zero is
the thickest setting we're gonna start
with that and then see we can go from
here oh come on look at mine all right
you go first
there we go okay okay so that's the
beginning it has to be a gradual process
slowly you get it thinner and thinner
which is why we're going wet from 0 to 7
to 7 like many times it's pretty
labor-intensive
it's why you need to people in push
squish squish we have the fettuccine
attachment I'm gonna put the crank over
here and then if you want to feed it
through okay you got it I do got it you
go okay that's one how to use my dough
might be here for a couple of hours Roth
is still cooking eight to twelve hours
is a very long time so we're gonna get
started on the pork the chashu we have a
pork belly here I think it's beautiful
piece of meat let's get close on because
this might get a little bit messy
because you know how when you go to
ramen shops you see that perfect circle
of meat that's what we're trying to
replicate we're gonna need to tie it
though because if you roll it up yasss
to do that so how about one person ties
the other person has to hold it together
alright hold it tight hold it tight roll
it up tight you want to go under the
meat and then oh wait that's how came
out it is slippery
hmm oh he's a key one there we go
oh no fingers are lost today all right
we have it in the pot we're gonna add
the braising liquid the soy sauce whirs
I know it looks like a lot of soy sauce
remember this is a giant pork roll yeah
it's like three bunches of scallions in
here
this is socket let's save some for me
oh they would run off with this then the
sweet line meeting and garlic
I got you ginger look at that good
timing well add a little bit of water to
top it off we're gonna braise this for a
while until it gets really nice really
tender the fats going to come out and
all of that sauce that just went in
there it's gonna seep right into the
meat
goodbye pork baby are you ready for this
I want to see you how are babies - one -
all right let's bring this to the Train
okay gently gently
all right the baby has landed it's very
tender it's very tender
cheers Cheers hmm this beautiful broth
right here we're saving it because we
are actually going to marinate our egg
in this sauce no ace yeah all right you
want to take care of that I want to
start wrapping this okay we have
something very special this is an
ostrich egg and this is a normal egg for
reference you know it's kind of like you
versus the guy she tells you not to
worry about this is not easy to break
and you've had like experience with
ostrich eggs and yes I have I have made
an ostrich egg egg McMuffin before yeah
this feels like a grenade like there's
no thin show sumo wrestler said he
wanted a nice soft boiled egg that's
kind of what ramen comes with it's like
nice right it's like beautiful its
marinated I think we're gonna have to
resort to a technique called sous-vide
essentially it's circulating water
around the egg at a fixed temperature to
cook it even all the way through this is
gonna go in the water do you want to
give it a name eggy okay cute baby
Peggy's gonna hang out in the water
we're gonna cross her face and wait for
a couple hours and see what goes on here
we are three hours later I'm just
nervous
I mean I know he's been sitting in there
for a long time soft-boiled though yeah
I don't know if it's gonna work but
there's no other way to find out then to
take it out and crack might open oh
gentle gentle
eggy we're gonna use the back of the
knife here where's more buns and just
slowly hack away at it
ready ready whenever you are felt that
one oh it's very soft it's like jello no
water boy I was just going to say that
okay okay it's definitely not cooks this
is not what a soft-boiled egg
[Music]
I think the yolk cooks way faster than
whites and Suvi is all about cooking at
an Emer temperature right so there's no
real way you can Suvi it where this is
under and this is over I think we might
have to sacrifice a soft-boiled egg and
just go with a harder boil it's better
to be safe and edible if it's not a
soft-boiled I think Amazon will
understand I would think he would
appreciate the fact that he is eating an
egg in not jello eggy I served as well
Haiti has served as well thank you for
his sacrifice may you rest in pieces
[Music]
moment of truth
you can you help me good okay emotional
support wouldn't be bad there
good job Elvin you've got this oh well
you can do it Elvin so we got a second
one what do you want to name it
eggy jr. good luck oh that's cute
do the honors know you gave him a face
he's just looking at me with the eyes
only one shot right this is one shot yes
is the last egg that we have and so it
continues to hammer his head with a
knife oh okay it's not let's focus on
let's focus on this side this is a
hard-boiled ostrich egg not the
prettiest thing but hey you know
sometimes children don't turn out the
way you want them to and that's okay we
love them we'll all the same we should
marinate this right yes okay we have
that
down to the marinade we're gonna add
some more soy sauce to this to help
cover it so you can get a full on bath
you don't want any white sauce
we're probably gonna leave this sitting
in there overnight I would say the damn
thick egg it is day 2 this has been
cooking for 12 hours let's go let's do
this oh it smells so good that is
delicious right Oh anything we can eat
everything in here
all of this stuff went into that broth
so you know the broth is gonna taste
good look at this nice and like milky
consistency
oh dear oh dear all right all right so
it's lo how he did it it's delicious
yeah I think we can always add more salt
and more flavour later we want it like
such as that sauce from the braise I
mean as Alvin says go big or go home
that's what I like to hear let's go pork
baby he's back it seems like it's
holding its shape fairly well gloves one
two three that was weak one two three
[Music]
that's a spiral of joy right there all
right that's one a slice number two oh
one of the most beautiful things you've
ever seen that's six slices hopefully
that is enough for this very amazing man
it is time to assemble we have our
beautiful eggy jr. here he has been
sitting in this little soy sauce meeting
suck it back for a while we have the
pork belly
ginger nori seaweed scallions and
obviously the broth but more importantly
enjoy my ramen and calls for it's like
the one my mom has it home like every
Asian family has a version of this and a
pair of pretty lone chopsticks to go as
our pretty big bowl oh so dark
wow this marinade really like sink in
Wow you want to cut the I can hold it
for you I don't want to cut your hand
these are tasty hands they're valuable
actually you know what all right cool
goodbye eggy whoa this guy's tough wait
hold up
break him open whoa cheers oh I think
the next thing we should do is to sear
the pork belly add some color to it like
how it looks in like ramen shop we could
sear it in a pan or pop in the oven or
time to get lick oh yeah all right agent
Lam proceed to target one copy that fire
will
status report agent lam target is slowly
burning huh
target known as pork baby is proving to
be quite resilient but there are signs
of distress good
like the fat is crisping a really nice
so fun
something about fires smoked meat and
fat it's like my favorite thing in the
world look at that look at that this is
the best day ever
we are now entering the noodle zone so
we have the noodles from yesterday we
have a pot of boiling water here and we
have an ice bath after I cook them I
dump it in ice water just so it lowers
the temperature and so it won't continue
cooking how many servings do you think
we're actually making here I think that
this big giant ramen bowl is gonna be
like 20 times the size of a normal bowl
of ramen this is the final mission we
should save the broth for last probably
build everything else first starting
with their noodles like that nice cool
right here I'll help you get the nori in
this beautiful pork coming in hot last
piece going in the prettiest girl at the
prom all right let's do the eggs get it
against the wall I want an egg in right
other egg is going nice Oh No let's tip
it over I'll do the Tokyo scallions some
touch some pickled ginger there it is
this is our oven this is this is a ramen
this is one ramen for a one minute well
we got a lot of liquid and I don't think
we have a lot of space to do yes what's
the strategy here
the strategy is there is no strategy too
weird for it until it's full I like this
strategy we're just gonna put in this
the braising sauce first okay
okay I want to go in with some broth
it's hot
that didn't even make a dent good thing
we made a lot of broth here we go again
good job this is actually the most
victorious I felt it's making a giant
burger I think this is done you think
we're ready to serve Jamison I think
he's a very hungry guy and I really want
to see if what we made stacks up to what
he expects because we put a lot of work
as well yeah you have my respect
ramen makers out there oh and we did
good good good I will clean up close
your eyes go go go almost there almost
there then turn around 1 2 3 open your
eyes we have that tonkotsu broth with a
homemade ramen noodles big cashew on
ostrich egg this this this is for you
thank you how do you feel are you hungry
yeah thank you
[Music]
[Music]
I would do this all over again in a
heart or soul do you think do you think
you can finish it all
are you can to everything okay so luxury
my friend coming here
oh yeah okay you're my grand akitoki Oh
[Music]
in the today I so very thank you so much
thank you
[Music]
we did it thank you for helping me today
definitely have not done it without you
the name of the show is taste he's
making a big I really don't think could
have gotten any bigger today a lot of
time and effort but I think it really
paid off it was really fun if you want
to guess what we're gonna be making
leave a comment send us a message and
thank you so much and we will see you
guys next time until then
[Music]
you
[Music]